[Musique]
bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver à la une de ça vous regarde ce
soir à battre le racisme en faisant
tomber des statures winston churchill
tagué à londres le roi léopold ii 2
déboulonné en belgique victor schoelcher
renversé en martinique et des appels à
retirer la statue de colbert devant
l'assemblée le week-end dernier ce genre
d'action se multiplient un peu partout
dans le monde depuis la mort de djordje
floyd la globalisation de l'antiracisme
passent par les mêmes gestes symboliques
et aussi polémique sommes-nous devenus
comme les américains obsédé par la race
et les identités décès faut-il réviser
notre histoire on en parle dans un
instant avec nos invités
et revoilà la réforme des retraites on
la croyait enterrée elle ressort du
placard arrière la proposition de loi
communiste sur les retraites des
agriculteurs a été adopté en commission
emmanuel macron est en train de
réfléchir à relancer cette réforme qui a
mis des millions de personnes dans la
rue pari risqué
on en parlera et puis comme chaque soir
le jour d'après nouvel épisode de notre
série d'entretiens sur l'après
coronavirus ce soir les stellistes david
djaïz analyse pour nous le retour en
force des états nation voilà donc pour
le programme c'est parti hashed accès
vers n'oubliez pas on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
regarder cette image nous sommes à
bristol royaume-uni dimanche dernier des
manifestants du mouvement black light
matters renversait la statue de l'ancien
esclavagiste edwards qu'olson et la
rouler au sol avant de la jeter dans le
canal statue érigée en 1895 depuis des
signes de protestation contre le racisme
comme celui ci se multiplient partout en
europe après le meurtre de john floyd on
va en parler ce soir avec vous corinne
narassiguin bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous est secrétaire national à la
coordination du parti socialiste et vous
avez signé cette semaine une tribune
remarquée intitulée le privilège
privilège blanc une ineptie dangereuse
on va y revenir et puis on attend
dominique sopo
le patron des sceaux est raciste qui
nous rejoint d'une minute à l'autre
ainsi que victorin lurel ancien ministre
d outre-mer depuis la guadeloupe qui
sera avec nous par skype je vous donne
la parole dans un instant celui qui va
nous planter le décor c'est cet
antiracisme qui nous vient tout droit
des etats-unis quand at il compris
stéphane blakowski tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane imbratta simple ce soir
pour vous qu'avez vous concocter en tout
cas moi si j'ai bien compris aujourd'hui
quand on vit en france c'est un
privilège d'être blanc alors à vrai dire
moi je veux bien admettre que ma vie
aurait été plus compliqué si je n'étais
pas blanc il ya des tas d'études qui ont
établi qu'il existait des
discriminations liées à la couleur de
peau de notre pays c'est plus difficile
de trouver un boulot plus difficile de
trouver un logement on est contrôlé plus
souvent par la police alors bien sûr
c'est regrettable et en même temps c'est
pas non plus si surprenant dans chaque
groupe humain il existe une tendance à
ce qu'on appelle l'ethnocentrisme c'est
à dire une tendance à dévaloriser tout
ce qui paraît étrange et aux normes du
groupe auquel on appartient c'est pas
moi qui ai inventé ça c'est un discours
de claude lévi strauss en 52 à l'unesco
s'appellera c'est l'histoire on étudie
ça normalement en place de philo en
terminale donc alors vu qu'en france la
majorité des habitants la peau blanche
d'un point de vue anthropologique
ça paraît presque inévitable que ceux
qui ont la peau d'une autre couleur soit
exposée à certaines formes de
discrimination bon évidemment c'est pas
parce que cette tendance à
l'ethnocentrisme existe dans chaque
groupe humain qu'il faut l'accepter
d'ailleurs en france on ne l'acceptent
pas le racisme avait puni par la loi
de très nombreux gouvernements mener des
campagnes contre les discriminations là
je vous montre une affiche de 2016
contre la discrimination au travail
le gouvernement actuel a lui aussi mené
des campagnes contre la discrimination
au travail
mais pour en revenir à ce concept de tri
villages blancs qui bien sûr est à
portée des états unis là où ça devient
gênant c'est quand on on vient affirmer
que les blancs défendent ce fameux
privilège coûte que coûte parce qu'ils
se croient supérieurs aux autres et ça
c'est ce que lilian thuram l'ancien
footballeur avait affirmé l'an dernier
donc je vous montre un petit extrait de
france info qui reprenait les
déclarations de thuram
alors évidemment en accusant tous les
blancs d'être des racistes thuram
c'était à son bord un tour retrouvée
accusée d'être raciste tous les
responsables du rassemblement national
s'était précipitée sans cette
déclaration pour dénoncer l'existence
d'un racisme anti blanc qui est un des
chevaux de bataille du
parti ben moi je crains un peu
aujourd'hui avec cette polémique sur le
fameux la privilège blanc on produise un
peu le même effet d'ailleurs marion
maréchal s'est immédiatement précipité
sur facebook pour faire une déclaration
en disant qu' elle ne s'excuserait pas
d'être blanche
et puis même elle a été plus loin elle
reproche aux militants antiracistes de
vouloir humilier les français on les
écoute il nous demandons seulement de
mettre à genoux mais en plus de ses
dires la mémoire de nos ancêtres de
cracher sur notre histoire de purger
notre héritage d'abattre nos statuts je
ne sais pas quel peuple digne de ce nom
et avec un minimum de fierté accepterait
de se plier à cette exigence
alors voyez il ya un instant je vous
parlais de 2,22 lilian thuram
donc forcément ça ça rappelle ce slogan
de la coupe du monde 98
cette victoire d'une équipe black blanc
beur quand il paraît qu'aujourd'hui on
est complètement naïf pour croire à sa
black blanc beur ben moi je sais pas je
l'aimé bien cette idée d'une france
black blanc beur peut-être que je suis
naïf j'espère juste que je suis pas le
seul simplement on va en parler merci
beaucoup stéphane vous restez avec nous
pour réagir et je salue l'arrivée de
dominique sopo bonsoir soit vous
présidez l'association sos racisme
vous avez entendu marion maréchal à
l'instant comment vous réagissez quand
elle explique pour résumer qu'elle n'a
pas à s'excuser d'être blanche qu'elle
n'est pas responsable du racisme aux
états unis notamment
côté jeux demandons à personne de
s'excuser parce que la personne serait
blanche ou d'ailleurs de n'importe quel
autre couleur de peau parce qu'on va
bien comment marion maréchal-le pen va
essayer d'être dans une forme de
retournement de perversion en
l'agenouillement au fait on demande aux
blancs de 7 juillet devant les noirs
mais enfin quand dire ces deux gestes de
martin luther king c'est le geste de
commandes dire de toute une série de
gens qui eux précisément sont des
personnes afro américaine
aux états unis on est dans quelque chose
chez marion maréchal-le pen qui en fait
sous quelque chose qui apparaît comme
étant très lisse et très raisonnable est
en fait une logique de retournement de
confrontation disant regardez en fait on
n'est plus vraiment chez nous il ya des
populations qui veulent nous imposer une
vision de l'histoire c'est toute cette
question du repentir de la repentance
alors que
massivement comment dire je pense que
les personnes d'origine maghrébine
subsaharienne ou descendante d'esclaves
sont bien au courant que les colons et
les négriers sont morts depuis longtemps
sur la l'école et en même temps il ya ce
concept c'est vrai le privilège blanc
qui nous vient tout droit des états unis
qui a été repris sur les réseaux sociaux
corinne narassiguin après l'ondé de choc
qui a provoqué le meurtre de george
floyd vous avez écrit dans le monde à ce
sujet d'abord c'est quoi cette idée de
privilèges blanc ans est née aux etats
unis les dépenses sociales américaines à
l'époque de la ségrégation raciale et
donc ça a été repris ensuite par les
activistes des militants de la cause
anti racistes contre la ségrégation
raciale aux états unis et à cette époque
là bien évidemment il y avait un
privilège blanc puisqu'il y avait un
statut
il y avait des droits exclusifs qui
était conféré aux blancs qui étaient
considérés effectivement dans la loi
comme étant supérieur et donc cette
histoire là il faut là il faut la
respecter par rapport à ce que sont les
états unis et l'histoire de la lutte
contre la ségrégation raciale aux états
unis puis c'est rester forcément dans
les luttes antiracistes aux états unis
d'autant qu'en plus aux états unis il ya
aussi des gens qui milite ouvertement
pour le retour de la ségrégation pour la
suprématie blanche ça existe et donc ça
c'est ça c'est leur histoire la nôtre
quand on parle de privilèges
on pense à la révolution française et
donc on pense alors l'abolition des
privilèges qui sont des privilèges
d'ordre patrimonial économique et social
et en fait quand on parle du coup de
privilégier ans a créé la confusion il
ya plein de beaucoup de populations
blanches en france qui vit vous parle la
précarité qui comprennent pas vous dites
je suis une femme noire dans le monde et
je suis contre le privilège blanc oui je
suis contre le l'utilisation
l'importation cette expression tels
quels des états unis en france parce que
on détourne du sujet on permet à des
personnes comme marion maréchal-le pen
de retourner là l'entreprise est en fait
ce jeu du front national on donne des
armes à tous ceux qui veulent faire
croire que la lutte antiraciste cetc
lutter contre les blancs alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait de cet antiracisme qui nous
vient des états unis qui a tendance à un
peu être obsédé par la question de la
race il faut le dire en tout cas qui
catégorise énorme m
les populations en d'identité blessé en
communauté femmes noirs juifs handicapés
homosexuels qu'est-ce qu'on en fait est
ce que cette vague là elle est en train
d'arriver en france à votre avis d'abord
ce qu'on veut faire remarquer que c'est
que souvent les états unis ont les
caricatures soit en positif soit en
négatif en fait on comment dire aux
états unis ont dit voilà sa catégorie ce
beaucoup c'est vrai qu'il ya cette
histoire là mais il n'ya pas que ça
d'ailleurs on voit bien que les
manifestations aujourd'hui aux
etats-unis sont des manifestations très
mélangées et que c'est toujours un peu
étonnant de voir comment on diabolise ou
comment au au contraire on va à
mythifier ce qui se passe aux etats-unis
sans même étude j ai vraiment ce qui s'y
passe en l'espèce avec de très très
fortes mes connaissances je pense que
cet antiracisme là avec l'histoire des
états unis
il a du bon il faut au fond prendre
exemple sur sept ans terrassé la en
france l'anti racisme aux états unis
évidemment qu'il ya du bon à prendre
dans l'anti racisme sur les modes de
mobilisation etc
il ya plein de choses sans doute bon à
prendre ceci étant lorsque l'on
travaille sur une société il faut
étudier la société sur laquelle on
travaille il ya des différences très
forte entre la france et les accuse les
états unis en matière de degré de
violence en matière de les etats unis
c'est le sol sur lequel les esclavages a
eu lieu alors en france ya encore des
territoires sur lesquels ils de
l'esclavagé dans le passé mais la
métropole pour l hexagone pour ne pas
reprendre un terme coloniale est une une
terre sur laquelle comment dire il n'y a
pas eu l'esclavagé bon donc il faut pas
tout mélanger il faut pas tout mélanger
et je pense que cette question de d'être
fasciné par ce qui se passe aux idées
dit ça renvoie de choses ça renvoie
d'abord à la capacité des états unis à
exporter son modèle et dans le modèle
américain
il ya aussi cette question non
réalisation d'antiracisme oui mais
comment dire les états unis exportent
aussi comment dire dans dans leur
culture mais aussi des mécanismes de
penser qu'ils sont des mécanismes de
pensée qui ne collent pas tout à fait à
ce que son d'autres sociétés évidemment
et le deuxième élément c'est je pense
une grande difficulté en phr
c'est qu'il a interroge je veux dire les
responsables politiques médiatiques
aussi sans doute ce sera la grande
difficulté à traiter du passé en france
et que lorsqu'on ne traîne à parler
passé en france est à la question c'est
que on va aller se raccrocher à un autre
pays dans lequel pour le coup l'histoire
allait raconter même si ça donne lieu à
des confrontations donc je pense qu'il
faut aussi réfléchir comment on traite
de l'histoire effet annonce stéphane
lacoste
j'ai l'impression que l'on parle du
modèle américain ans en défiant un petit
peu comme si on pouvait en fait éviter
que ça se produise en france je me
demande si c'est pas déjà produit depuis
longtemps jérôme fourquet avec six mois
dernier un requin qui a beaucoup fait
parler d'elle l'archipel français où
justement il notait que la france se
fera de montagne notamment sur les
critères de communauté à base ethnique
c'est le travail d'un seul hyper
respecter on est vraiment déjà dans le
modèle américain en france alors qu'on
ne l'a pas forcément souhaité qu il ya
effectivement il ya un phénomène qui
arrive depuis je virais peut-être deux
décennies en france mais aux états unis
c'est l'histoire de leur peuplement donc
c'est beaucoup plus anciens l'histoire
de leur peuplement c'est une histoire de
peuplement par communauté nous on a une
histoire qui est beaucoup plus longue
beaucoup plus complexe avec des vagues
d'immigration des vagues de mélange on
est un pays carrefour dans l'europe on a
eu cette histoire aussi de la
colonisation et donc c'est une histoire
qui est très complexe et et je crois que
c'est parce que notamment la gauche a un
peu un peu échoué échoué à résoudre la
question de la lutte contre être
efficace non dans la lutte contre le
racisme et contre les dix l'antiracisme
à la française n'a pas réussi et un
autre anti racisme pluralité presque
mais au brésil 6 me a river sont pas non
plus complètement aux états unis en août
on doit on voit bien que ça ne réussit
pas non plus aux états d'âme et mais du
coup parce que parce qu'il ya eu une
présence médiatique forte parce que
parce qu'on les entend alors si c'est
eux qui occupent le terrain la honte
d'être blanc a supplanté la mauvaise
conscience bourgeoise
c'est alain finkielkraut qui dit ça dans
le figaro aujourd'hui pour lui
ça fait pas doute cette vague anti
racistes à l'américaine avait déjà là je
croyais être d'accord ou pas moi je moi
je suis pas d'accord moi je peins je
pense que ja il ya des échos il ya des
échos il ya des choses où on voit il ya
cette tentation il ya une volonté aussi
militants de certains groupes de
d'importer cette forme de militantisme
séparatistes en france mais je pense que
la majorité des français qui se
retrouvent un petit peu entraîné la
danse pour ça je parlais du silence de
la majorité de la gauche c'est que c'est
que parce qu'il ya ce silence la deux il
n'y a pas eu assez de discours qui sur
les bases républicaines traditionnelle
de la france que ceux qui veulent lutter
contre le racisme s'attache à ceux qui
parlent qui en parlent le plus et ceux
qui en parlent le plus aujourd'hui c'est
ceux qui sont dans les combat
identitaire malheureusement et donc
voilà donc la ca c'est à nous de
reprendre la passe parce que l'histoire
de la république elle est plus long que
les quelques années où on commence à
voir c'est très demandé à l'orme à voir
comment vous reprendre ou pas la place
bonsoir victorin lurel
merci d'être avec nous depuis des
antilles depuis la guadeloupe
vous êtes sénateur socialiste ancien
ministre d outre-mer on va parler des
statues dans un instant je sais que le
sujet vous vous tient à coeur mais je
voulais vous faire réagir
toujours sur cette question de
l'antiracisme aux états unis on a vu le
film autant en emporte le vent qui a été
retirée temporairement par la plateforme
edge bio la série américaine friends qui
s'excuse également de ne pas avoir donné
assez de place à des acteurs noirs
je peux citer d'autres exemples la
chaîne paramount qui a retiré sa série
coop c'est ce que vous cautionnez ça ou
c'est une forme de censure finalement et
ça c'est la culture américaine c'est la
culture américaine et qui quoi qu'on en
dise arrive déjà est déjà arrivée à
paris dans l'hexagone mais vous vous en
féliciter ou pas ah on est loin
forcément depuis la guadeloupe
en tout cas c'est le pétrifie dominique
sopo il va revenir il va revenir à
victorin lurel
on va parler des statuts tout de suite
et puis je suis sûr qu'on retrouvera la
liaison c'est clément mérite qui a
préparé un petit sujet parce que je vous
le disais dans le sommaire on ne compte
plus un depuis
à mort de john floyd le nombre de
statues elles sont différentes selon les
pays selon ce qu'elle représente
mais qui sont des volumes déboulonner ou
retirer regardez ces images on va
s'intéresser chez nous juste à côté à la
statue de colbert figurez vous que la
semaine dernière le week-end dernier
très précisément cette statue qui se
situe devant les colonnes du palais
bourbon et bien a fait l'objet d'une
manifestation regardez c'est une statue
qui trône devant l'assemblée depuis 200
ans
aujourd'hui certains veulent la
déboulonner colbert les manuels
scolaires se souviennent du génial
contrôleur des finances de louis xiv
mais les descendants d'esclaves eux
retiennent l'auteur du code noir
cette statue est une abomination on a
voté la loi taubira l'assemblée
nationale qui reconnaît l'esclavagé
comme crime contre l'humanité et en même
temps on célèbre l'esclavagiste celui
qui a organisé le coc noir celui qui a
créé la compagnie des indes sinistre
mémoire qui a déporté des milliers
d'africains
c'est à dire qu'albert il faut enseigner
nice 3 bien sûr il faut enseigner
colbert mais il faut pas honorer colbert
or nous faisons linverse faut-il passer
notre histoire au filtre de nos valeurs
contemporaines cette position fait débat
chez les historiens
je comprends très bien qu'on a envie
d'éliminer cette statue qu'on ne la voit
plus comme beaucoup d'autres mais en
même temps je pense que l'idée qu'on va
supprimer les statuts et obtenir une
espèce de mon nouveau transparent faire
table rase me paraît me paraît illusoire
l'histoire de l'exclavage l'histoire
coloniale c'est une très longue histoire
qui construit aussi la france qui
construit aussi l'europe
ça fait partie de notre héritage colbert
à l'assemblée ce n'est pas qu'une statue
c'est aussi une salle qu'il faudrait
rebaptiser et ailleurs en france ce sont
des dizaines de rues de place ou de
lycée qu'il faudrait redonner
dominique sopo quelle est votre position
sur sur colbert est sûre au fond les
stacul les effigies les salles les
boulevards les lycées colbert
est-ce qu'il faut choses différentes
entre colbert et les statuts par 17 6 là
on a une statue vous la connaissez pas
fait tout aléa tout près de la place de
la concorde ans quand l'assemblée bondir
sur la question des statuts il faut
distinguer les raisons pour lesquelles
une personne à une statue notamment aux
états unis par exemple il ya deux ans je
crois y avait tout ce mouvement en
disant il faut déboulonner les statues
du général lee qui représente le passé
sudiste et ségrégationniste mais le
général lee les statues du général y
avait été mis je crois dans les années
1920 bien avant vient après la fin de la
guerre de sécession pour réaffirmer dans
les états du sud l'ordre
ségrégationniste est donc là c'était
pour valoriser la ségrégation ses
limites colbert sa statue elle n'a pas
été mise parce que il a rédigé le code
noir qui est une invitation par futur
nous le cadre noir le code noir c'est ce
qui codifie précisément la question de
la gestion des territoires où il y adeux
de l' esclavage à cette époque sans 785
qu'il est rédigé et qui codifie la
question des peines etc qui d'ailleurs
exclu les juifs d'ailleurs des de ces
territoires parce que l'esclavagé est
aussi présentée comme à un vaste
mouvement d'évangélisation des
populations sous la fois sous la foi
catholique qui définit le noir comme
étant un bien meuble et c'est bon mais
si on sait la france aujourd'hui qu'on
n'est pas à cause du non le ministre de
louis xiv
évidemment mais évidemment il ya une
question c'est que colbert et bien le
rédacteur d'une d'une abomination mais
il peut y avoir un appareillage
critiques autour des statuts ou même
autour de certaines oeuvres culturelles
puisqu'on parlait de autant en emporte
le vent
quand on est face je pense à une oeuvre
culturelle
il vaut mieux rajouter de la culture
plutôt que supprimer la culture je pense
que l'épaisseur culturel c'est aussi le
chemin à travers lequel on peut
précisément avant cet appareil critique
mais vous n'êtes pas pour déboulonner
cette statue qui si tu n as donc je
pense que je tiens ce qu'il y a
critique parce que ça fait partie de
l'histoire de france et de l'évolution
aussi de la façon de l'appréhender c'est
très intéressant d'ailleurs mais je vais
dire faisant de la culture de la
profession mère corinne narassiguin je
suis tout à fait je rejoins complètement
dominique sopo je pense que la question
c'est que je comprends l'émotion qui
conduit à vouloir déboulonner l'état une
attention singulière à thouars on a
souvent déboulonner les statues en cire
asticots et voilà mais je crois
qu'effectivement le problème le problème
de d'exprimer cette colère de cette
manière là c'est qu'effectivement c'est
pas parce qu'on n'efface les traces de
l'histoire que on va en diminuer le
poids
et puis je crois que c'est aussi parce
que on ne s'approprie pas suffisamment
l'histoire de france si on s'était
approprié l'histoire de france il y
avait une pancarte à côté en dessous de
la statue de colbert qui explique qu'il
était dans dans ce qu'il a fait de bien
pour la france sur l'interface
l'intervention est d'état l'organisation
administrative et mémé on explique aussi
ce qu'il a fait de rible sur le causse
noir il il ya les habilleuses vous
voulez que on accompagne un maximum la
connaissance bien sûr qu'il y ait de la
pédagogique d'éducation
il faut qu'on s'approprie son histoire
moi j'exerce à l'usagé quasi
s'adresserait le oui j'espère que ça le
faire abolitionnistes qui est laissée
l'heure où l'esclavagé c'est là où on
voit que ça devient irrationnel il ya 6
et de l'émotion et cbi rationnel quand
vous condamnez c'est ça montre quand
même une forte mes connaissances puisque
notamment souvent on reproche à
schoelcher d'avoir indemnisé les les
esclavagistes mais d'abord ce n'était
pas sa position à lui et lui sa position
à schoelcher c'était d'indemniser les
esclaves au demeurant et on peut pas
nier le combat qu'a mené schoelcher qui
était un combat où il a été totalement
minoritaires et conspué pendant des
années avant qu'il y ait l'abolition de
l'esclavagé en 1811 en 1848 donc
évidemment on peut critiquer les
conditions dans lesquelles l'abolition
de l'esclavagé s'est faite sans aucun
doute cette question de l'indemnisation
des esclavagistes
le fait qu'on ne passe pas de l'ombre à
la lumière du jour au lendemain on
comment dire on le sait bien la question
de la non remise à plat des richesses
dans les anciennes colonies entre les
anciens esclavagistes et les
anciens esclaves dont il ya plein de
choses à dire mais justement parlons-en
abattre une statue ne règle pas grand
chose ceci étant si on n'a pas des
statuts c'est aussi parce que mon avis
il ya un manque de débat sur ces sujets
c'est très dur en france de parler mais
il n'y a pas d'espoir en fait il ya pas
d espace de débat comment dire quasiment
sur ces sujets à l'université par
exemple dans l'espace public
très peu on nous fait des efforts on a
une journée de la mémoire de l'esclavagé
mais on a on a on a créé une fondation
et a pas très longtemps sous vos
françois hollande mais que jean marc
ayrault qui a sa tête aujourd'hui mais
on n'a pas de onze de départ organisée
sur l'esclavagisme
quel est le débat vous voulez organiser
hier on sait qu'à des pour et des
contres aujourd'hui séparément mais ben
en fait j'avais cessé de plus vulgarisée
cette histoire là c'est s'approprier le
fait que oui il y a un poids de
l'esclavagisme et du colonialisme dans
l'histoire française qui se structure
encore la société française et kick
équipe et fait perdurer cette région qui
fait persuadé d'avoir assisté milk en
france qui existe encore aujourd'hui
s'il ya des discrimination systémique en
france aujourd'hui c'est parce que parce
que les conséquences de cette histoire
là se continue à ce qu'est ce que
voulait dire par systémique c'est pas la
même chose que institutionnels
évidemment le racisme la discrimination
c'est illégal en france
mais la réalité c'est que il y à un
ensemble de préjugés et de stéréotypes
de comportement qui convergent pour
faire pour pour créer des applications
qui sont pas les deux personnes isolées
excusez moi tout à l'heure quand je veux
citer que lesdits strauss dans son
discours à ses histoires qui disait que
l'ethnocentrisme est quelque chose qui
existait dans chaque groupe humain
on sait que ça n'existe qu'en france de
l'ethnocentrisme
mais quel rapport en fait vous voyez
comment dire c'est géré sentiment c'est
non en fait ce qui est très intéressant
c'est comment tout de suite l'émotion
elles montrent comment tout de suite les
gens se sentent en accusation vous voyez
il ya plein de débats sur la question
d'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
on ad on ne vient pas dire sauf certains
écoutez vous êtes bien gentil les femmes
de nous parler d'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes mais il n'y a pas
qu'en france que ça existe
même mais c'est marrant sur ces sujets à
chaque fois qu'on en parle tout de suite
il ya une montée en émotions et si à
cette montée en émotions c'est
précisément parce qu'il n'y a pas d'
espaces comment dire de débats suffisant
parce qu on se rendrait compte que si
elle expliqué on vous avait de fait
quand même un des bacs en ondes en
installant qui des noms n'y a pas deux
attendez pas juger censure bondir mais
pas une question sur si les débats ne
sont pas organisés en fait il se passe
ce qui se passe rien c'est tout le débat
n'a pas lieu c'est tout monde il n'y a
pas de sens il n'ya pas quelqu'un qui
dit surtout n'en parlons pas il n'y a
pas un bureau de la censure
je remarque que dans notre pays c'est
extrêmement compliqué de parler de ce
passé là qui est aussi un passé qui est
en lien que la république je rappelle
que certes la république a aboli à
chaque fois qu'elle a été proclamée elle
a aboli l esclavage mais c'est que la
république était colonial la grande
époque coloniale c'est la troisième
république
c'est pas évident de dire ça parce
qu'elle payerait big c'est aussi la
république qui c'est vrai d'ailleurs met
en oeuvre définitivement les acquis de
la révolution française
un siècle après la révolution donc on
essaie donc on est dans des complexités
à tout arrêt dans des complexes ya tout
un travail à la fois à faire sur sur la
mémoire de l esclavage auprès de la
société française on a retrouvé victorin
lurel mais je crois qu'il est en ligne
et non pas à l'image bonsoir victorin
lurel
je voulais que vous nous expliquer quel
était votre position sur sur la statue
de colbert vous êtes sénateur et cette
statue et de figure aussi dans
l'hémicycle du sénat
vous êtes favorable à la levée je crois
je suis absolument favorable pour
l'enlever
alors je sais bien qu'en dix ans âge
avait choqué beaucoup de mes collègues
mais j'avais déjà fait des textes voire
des conférences pour dire que ce fonds
ne sombrez dans la repentance puisque
nous avons été victimes pas si longtemps
de ça ne lorsque le président sarkozy a
décidé au nom de la non content de ne
pas idée à la construction du mémorial
acte en bois de l'eau malgré un très
beau rapport fait par les droits de
licence au président chirac avait
accepté après le succès sera refusé il y
as est implanté alors oui c'est vrai que
nous partageons une histoire commune
nous sommes des victoires de la
république
il ya tellement de choses qui n'ont au
rachat mais il est certain c'est très
difficile encore aujourd'hui peut-être
plus aujourd'hui qu'hier
il ya une difficulté à assumer le passé
à le reconnaître à l'assumer
peut-être à le dépasser c'est compliqué
alors lorsque l'on dit je pense et
georges louis georges tin qui a dit ça
vos héros sont au bord ou alors c'est
une phrase terrible mais lorsque vous
avez que c'est quand même colbert qui a
fait le code noir et que vous entrez
l'assemblée nationale vous avez une
statue dressé très fièrement et presque
triomphalement à l'entrée il ya de quoi
blesser quelqu'un renan de l'afrique et
en particulier venant d outre mer
lorsque vous parlez à la tribune du
sénat vous est surplombée par là dessus
de colbert alors en dix ans a
effectivement je vais choquer beaucoup
de français hexagonaux mais comprenez un
descendant un arrière petit fils
d'esclave qui s'exprime sous l'ombre
tutélaire de colbert dit oui avec
l'établissement dans le segment qui
devrait être l'un pour enseigner
l'histoire de manière dépassionnée de
colère
merci merci victorin lurel d'un beau je
voudrais vous entendre pour conclure est
vraiment rapidement notre modèle le
modèle universaliste républicain qui ne
reconnaît que des citoyens sans
étiquette il a de l'avenir ou pas parce
que et quand même mal en point tout
modèle est le fruit d'un combat et
n'oubliez pas non plus que les états
unis c'est aussi qu'on dit ce sont aussi
construit sur un universalisme
je vais être optimiste oui oui
absolument
merci merci à tous les deux d'être
revenue sur 70 on va parler à présent de
la réforme des retraites et non et bien
n'est pas morte l'exécutif veut sauver
au moins une partie hier à l'assemblée
nationale les députés de la majorité ont
adopté une proposition de loi communiste
sur les os de pension pour les
agriculteurs elle faisait partie de la
réforme qui a été prévu stéphanie tpr
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée en
conséquence
est considéré comme adopté le projet de
loi instituant un système universel de
retraite
c'était le 3 mars dernier
mais le coronavirus va changer la donne
la loi n'ira pas au sénat et le 16 mars
emmanuel macron décrète le confinement
nous sommes en guerre toute l'action du
gouvernement et du parlement doit être
désormais tournés vers le combat contre
l'épidémie
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé que toutes
les réformes en cours seraient suspendus
à commencer par la réforme des retraites
trois mois plus tard la france ceux des
confine la vie parlementaire retrouve un
rythme presque normale et hier les
députés n'ont pas nouveau parler des
retraites un avis culture sur trois à
une retraite inférieure à trasher 350
euros par mois c'est la réalité
les députés discutaient en fait d'une
proposition de loi communiste datant de
2010 est pour revaloriser les pensions
des agriculteurs à 1000 euros minimum et
la majorité l'a accepté la réforme des
retraites
elle est toujours en suspens mais elle
n'est pas enterrée le président de la
république veut même la relancer et la
majorité s'y prépare les réponses sont
qui est apportée par la réforme des
retraites sont d'autant plus à mon avis
à l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui
on voit bien que certaines caisses
autonomes sont fragilisés on voit aussi
aujourd'hui que des personnes qui
étaient au premier rang pendant cette
crise
les caissières les soignantes beaucoup
de femmes je le dis au féminin à dessins
sont aussi les personnes qu'on souhaite
revaloriser
on ne va pas évidemment prendre le texte
tel qu'il était sorti il y a quelques
mois
ne rien changer c'est une évidence dont
la majorité certains estiment qu'il ne
faut pas relancer un grand projet de loi
retraites mais distiller la réforme par
petites touches au gré des textes à
venir
d'autres évoquent aussi des difficultés
de calendrier
je suis favorable oui un système par
points je suis favorable oui à ce qu'on
corrige les unités je suis favorable à
ce qu'on équilibre le système je suis
toujours défavorable à l'âge pivot comme
je lé toujours été mais par contre j'ai
aussi une forme de lucidité
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui je ne peux
pas promettre aux électeurs qui sont les
nôtres je peux pas promettre aux
français que nous serons en mesure de
faire cette réforme avant la fin du
quinquennat et je crois qu'il ya surtout
d'autres grandes priorités en 2017 on
été élu avec une priorité sur l'emploi
sur la lutte contre le chômage de masse
cette priorité revient au centre du jeu
aujourd'hui
et c'est là dessus que nous devons nous
concentrer quoi qu'il arrive ce sont le
président de la république et le
gouvernement qui reste maître du
calendrier et nous ont rejoints sur ce
plateau stéphane peu bonsoir vous êtes
député communiste de seine saint denis
cette proposition de loi de votre
collègue andré chassaigne elle va
arriver dans l'hémicycle la semaine
prochaine elle vise donc à revaloriser
les pensions des agriculteurs à 85% du
smic c'est 75% et vous aller la soutenir
une fois n'est pas coutume sandra mottin
bonsoir est-ce qu'on des députés la
république en marche de l'isère donc
cette réforme des retraites
elle n'est pas morte elle va revenir je
crois effectivement qu'elle n'est pas
morte elle ne l'a jamais été le
président et premier ministre ont
toujours dit qu'elle était suspendue
effectivement d'autres choses à faire en
ce moment mais concrètement elle n'est
pas morte elle est passée au forceps
49,3 el amine des millions de personnes
dans la rue il ya eu covidien a été
suspendu elle n'est pas populaire alors
que les français vont souffrir et vous
la remettez sur la table elle n'est pas
populaire en l'état dans la dans le
contexte dans lequel on la beauté qui
tout à fait différent de celui dans
lequel on est aujourd'hui dans lequel on
sera demain effectivement il ya
énormément de choses qui ont été mal
comprises qui n'ont peut-être même pas
été entendu mais qui aujourd'hui nous
pousse justement à ce que vous allez
garder ce que vous allez jeter
moi je souhaite qu'on garde par exemple
la retraite à 1000 euros grâce à nos
collègues de du groupe gdr on va là
voter effectivement pour les
agriculteurs et ils nous ont même aidé
à aller plus loin que ce qu'on voulait
faire en prenant aussi des agriculteurs
qui sont actuellement à la retraite et
qui vont pouvoir en bénéficier
mais moi je n'oublie pas qu'il ya des
artisans des commerçants des
indépendants si on avait promis aussi
qu'il vont être touchés de plein fouet
par la crise comme l'a dit ma collègue
catherine fabre dans votre sujet les
femmes qui sont aussi souvent les
premières victimes de la crise
il faut qu'on arrive à les protéger leur
gardien les bonnes mesures l'animosité
mais on le fait aussi avec
responsabilité
alors je crois que la veille avoir la
toison d'or je crois en vo c'est un des
irritants je pense qu'il faut qu'on leur
mette tout sur la table
moi je suis prête à lâcher et abandonné
l'âge pivot si les partenaires sociaux
nous propose des solutions et ils vont
devoir de toute façon on trouvé pour
faire vous êtes prête vous le souhaitez
vous êtes député
moi je souhaite ne retireront pas leurs
rivaux moi je souhaite que les
partenaires sociaux nous fasse des
propositions entre les partenaires
sociaux mais les partenaires sociaux
vont devoir se saisir de ce sujet parce
que la crise dans laquelle nous rentrons
c'est aussi moins 20 % de recettes pour
les caisses de retraite on a donc de
toute façon aujourd'hui une situation
totalement différente de celle dans
laquelle nous étions en mars alors
j'espérais à laquelle il va falloir
apporter des je vais vous faire réagir
dans un instant stéphane peu mais on va
rejoindre rafael de gens notre
chroniqueur économique parce qu'il sait
lui ce que prépare le chef de l'état
bonsoir raphaël alors quelle est la
stratégie d' emmanuel macron sur les
retraites
sa stratégie allez extrêmement politique
effectivement c'était bien dit dans le
reportage qui s'est retrouvé en première
ligne pendant la crise et elle est
caissière c'était des petits salaires
c'est elles et à acheter c'est à dire
exactement les profits étaient les
grands bénéficiaires de la réforme des
retraites n'est donc pas question de
gâcher cette cartouche notamment en
prévision de 2022 puisque ce serait un
argument important pour parler allèles
gauche de son électorat
alors évidemment le texte ne sera pas
repris tel quel mais on a déjà quelques
petites informations sur ce qui pourrait
rester tab à 1
le pilier de la réforme c'est à dire le
régime universel par points
question simplicité la la hausse du
minimum retraite aussi à 1000 euros on
en a parlé évidemment de rester une
question peut-être un peu plus compliqué
qui est celle de
ce pivot de l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation va revenir sur la table car
il faudra travailler plus longtemps pour
la pérennité du régime et par contre
c'est une question qui reste
effectivement sur la table en discussion
avec les partenaires sociaux
c'est celle de la suppression des
régimes spéciaux une question
extrêmement sensible et la du grain à
moudre pour être donnés aux syndicats
soit en ménageant des temps de
transition un peu plus long et plus
généreux ou alors en proposant une
évolution un peu plus longue pour les
régimes autonome comme les avocats par
exemple qui avaient beaucoup manifesté
contre le fait qu'en cifom leurs caisses
alors pour l'instant l'elysée indique
être dans une gare de triage
les partenaires sociaux devraient
participer au tri des mesures que l'on
garde ou que l'on jette et on devrait en
savoir un petit peu plus alors pas dès
dimanche lors de l'allocution solennelle
puisque le président de bell plutôt
clôturait la séquence coronavirus mais
dans un deuxième discours très attendu
entre le second tour des municipales le
28 juillet le 28 juin à pardon et le 14
juillet où emmanuel macron devraient
dessiner un peu plus précisément ce
qu'il souhaite faire d'ici la fin du
quinquennat
merci beaucoup raphaël on fera pas
dimanche mais vous dans cette gare de
triage stéphane qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous et gardez de cette réforme
je voulais c'est ce débat est assez
étonnant moisson commandes des
suppositions donc c'est toujours un peu
un peu difficile comme exercice mais
c'est un peu étonnant que la promesse
d'un monde d'après se traduisent par le
retour
du monde d'avant et la réforme des
retraites c'est vraiment le monde
d'avant c'était bien vous a été lui
c'est une faute politique a votre avis
il va le payer cher
mouais enfin j'entends des voix dans la
majorité ou qui sont proches du
président de la république commencer par
françois bayroux qui avec qui ne cesse
de recommander qu'après la crise que
l'on vient de connaître
il y ait de l'apaisement qu'on essaye de
faire valoir des réformes ou des projets
qui ne divise pas les français comme la
réforme des retraites a été sans doute
13 en même temps si je me permets de
vous avez contribué à remettre sur la
table avec cette proposition de loi sur
les agriculteurs oui oui non mais enfin
là il ya un très mauvais parallèle qui
est fait je vais vous faire un petit
historique en deux minutes manquerait un
très rapidement la loi chassaigne dont
on parle aujourd'hui elle a été votée à
l'unanimité de l'assemblée nationale
sous la précédente législature
c'était en février 2017 quelques mois
avant les élections présidentielles elle
a ensuite été votée dans la nouvelle
mandature à l'unanimité du sénat
et c'est le gouvernement actuel alors
qu'il y avait l'unanimité la majorité du
sénat et d'unanimité de l'assemblée
nationale la program manager qui a qui a
refusé cette cette réforme parce qu'en
fait c'est pas une réforme sur les
retraites
daloa chassaigne sait comment les
retraités agricoles aujourd'hui qui
vivent dans la misère peuvent avoir une
pension revalorisée
je me reconnais donc le minimum
contributif à mille euros c'est la même
philosophie ce pack wii par des
agriculteurs
mais avec sept ans de retraite elle
était pour les retraités à venir
la sonatel saluer une grosse différence
a fait quand même une salière différent
bien de nous avons rejoint et non mais
très bien mais c'est une très bonne
chose mais il voulait y a pas de
relation entre 7,7 loichat same chi chi
le kill que je faut lui rendre hommage
pour son opiniâtreté depuis maintenant
quatre ans il se bat pour sept sujets
qui fâchent sandra mottin travailler
plus longtemps travaillé jusqu'à 64 65
ans alors qu'elle est déjà un million de
chômeurs de plus et qui va en avoir
sûrement encore plus
est ce que c'est bien raisonnable sur le
fond je ne parle même pas de
l'opportunité politique
sur le fond on est bien clair à chaque
fois qu'on est confronté à une crise et
qu' il ya une flambée du chômage en
france a été le cas en 2008 a été de
nouveau le cas en 2012
on se rend compte que deux ans plus tard
on est obligé de prendre des mesures
drastiques sur les gains sur les
retraites après 2008
on a eu 2010 et la réforme fillon qui a
porté l'âge de la retraite à 62 ans
après 2012 on a eu 2014 la réforme de
marisol touraine qui a porté l'âge en
réalité à 64 ans par l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est qu'est ce qu'on veut
faire
est ce que on attend deux ans pour
régler le problème
ou est ce qu'on se dit tous ensemble que
on va en toute responsabilité avec les
partenaires sociaux avec l'ensemble des
groupes politiques réfléchir à la
manière dont on veut effectivement
régler le problème de ce problème de
recettes qui va qui est liée à la crise
et au chômage
et est-ce qu'on en profite pour donner
plus de droits et on va en profiter par
exemple pour donner des droits à des
gens mois auquel je pense parce qu'ils
vont être très touchés par la crise ce
sont les gens qui sont proches de la
retraite
aujourd'hui qui risquent d'être touchés
de plein fouet par la crise qui vont se
retrouver sur le carreau
si demain quand tu auras de la reprise
on leur permet pas par exemple s'ils
peuvent faire du cumul emploi-retraite
d'acquérir des droits comme on proposait
qu'en tire travail
eh ben on les laissera effectuera une
urgence à la règle sur le sujet
rapidement j'ai pas pu m'exprimer effet
jugé il a fallu que j'explique la loi
chasse un débat très franchement les
français ont compris que cette réforme
des retraites a visé deux choses partir
plus tard pour des pensions plus faibles
parce que quand on calcule sur toute la
durée de la vie forcément et notamment
les femmes les petits salaires sont les
premiers pas sont les premiers pénalisés
je peux vous citiez mille exemples les
gens ils ont fait leur calcul vaut mieux
les 25 mai lors du débat
retenons c'est une arrivée c'est une
réforme qui divise profondément le pays
qui a tout au long du débat soit la
réforme des retraites elle avait
l'hostilité de l'immense majorité des
français demandait donc il faut pas
notamment
non je demande à ce que on est une
réforme qui soit une réforme qui apaise
et qui rassemble et pour cela il faut
mettre à contribution la roma il faut
mettre les débats pourquoi pas ne pas
faire à utiliser les relais la
rémunération du capital par exemple une
vieille recette 40 d'après ça je suis
sûr je suis sûr qu'on aura n'existe pas
d'en reparler longuement on attend
maintenant savoir ce que dira le
président de la république sur cette
réforme c'est l'heure de l'histoire du
jour de thomas des prêts thomas qui va
nous raconter l'envers du décor sur les
masques que les députés porte vous le
savez c'est obligatoire à l'assemblée
nationale et quelque chose me dit qu'ils
ne sont ni colo ni made in france n'est
ce pas thomas oui exactement myriam
aujourd'hui je vous parlais de ces
masques ils sont partout mais est ce que
vous savez d'où ils viennent
et bien pas forcément de france je vous
raconte tout ça on a tous vu ces images
d' emmanuel macron le mois dernier dans
une école à poissy avec un très beau
masque noir logo bleu blanc rouge qui
est disponible sur ce site internet à 15
euros 30 le masque président mais
figurez vous qu ici à l'assemblée
nationale tous les députés ne portent
pas du made in france
et parfois ils ne savent même pas d'où
viennent leurs masques de députés est ce
que vous savez d'où vient votre masque
bonne question est ce que vous savez
d'où vient votre masque absolument pas
il vient de l'assemblée nationale et
on l'a gracieusement fourni à son entrée
alors voix l'assemblée nationale vous
portez donc un masque france est tout à
fait bien sûr en fait au début de la
crise la france a commandé à des
millions de masques venus d'un peu
partout de la planète principalement en
chine au détriment de certaines
entreprises françaises qui elles aussi
se sont mis à fabriquer des masques et
ce sujet il dérange
un député de la république en marche qui
du coup a eu une idée
bonjour denis masseglia ont fortement
des prêts alors vous vous avez eu l'idée
d'envoyer des masques à tous vos
collègues députés exactement j'ai
souhaité envoyer à chacun de mes
collègues et aussi à chaque personne du
gouvernement à chaque ministre est
secrète un état de masques yen à un noir
comme celui ci avec deux élastiques sur
le côté et donc le drapeau bleu blanc
rouge ici et le second exactement le
même mais de couleur blanche alors ces
masques réutilisables ils ont un
avantage celui de ne pas polluer
contrairement aux masques jetables qu'on
retrouve dans les jardins dans les parcs
dans les caniveaux et peut-être bientôt
dans nos plages et sur ce sujet au
ministère de la transition écologique et
solidaire on est mobilisé
bonjour veaux par sont alors vous vous
êtes très engagée depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant pour les masques
réutilisables et surtout contre les
masques jetables
absolument on se retrouve aujourd'hui
fassent effectivement à des pratiques
qui sont ni respectueuse de
l'environnement ni respectueuse tout
simplement des règles de base de la
civilité avec des masques qui se
retrouve sur nos trottoirs il faut bien
se dire une chose c'est que si on veut
des mers propres si on veut des océans
propres alors ça commence par avoir des
trottoirs qui sont propres
c'est pour ça qu'on a décidé de durcir
les sanctions avec une amende qui va
passer de 68 euros à 135 et qui pourra
aller jusqu'à 375 euros
alors nous ce matin avec l'équipe on a
été à l'accueil de l'assemblée nationale
où nous avons distribué ces masques là
comme il les distribuer à tous les
députés
c'est pas un peu incohérent est ce qu'il
faudrait pas qu'ils distribuent des
masques réutilisables alors je suis
membre de l'exécutif je ne peux donc pas
et ce n'est pas à moi de juger de ce que
fait la branche législative c'est-à-dire
l'assemblée nationale en revanche dans
la mesure du possible c'est vrai qu'il
est bien préférable pour l'environnement
pour le porte monnaie et pour aussi
l'emploi et l'économie française
d'utiliser des masses qui sont justement
réutilisables voilà mejia mais pour être
tout à fait complet brune poisson qui
nous a aidé
indiqué que depuis 2018 le gouvernement
travaillait à une filière de recyclage
des masques jetables usagers mais ça on
aura sans doute l'occasion de reparler
dans ma journée à l'assemblée
voilà pour la chronique de thomas des
prêts chaque jeudi depuis le début du
déconfinement il nous fait découvrir les
députés comme personne bonsoir camille
saféris ravissante alors avec kid et
nous vous avez pris l'apéro cette
semaine alors cette semaine j'ai pris
l'apéro avec jean paul mattei c'est un
député modem des pyrénées atlantiques de
la 2e circonscription et nous nous
sommes vus au café néons dans le xviiie
arrondissement de paris en terrasse
alors jean paul mattei c'est un proche
de françois bayroux c'est un docteur il
est d'ailleurs toujours en activité sera
d'ailleurs et il a une passion jean paul
mattei c'est la voile il aime beaucoup
la mer il a même son propre bateau sur
la côte basque le coup bonne un voilier
de 12 mètres et à l'arrivée des courses
il a monté un club de députés fans de
voile toutes couleurs politiques
confondues
évidemment mais attention pas de conflit
sur la direction pas question de barrer
à droite ou à gauche
on est tous dans le même bateau et c'est
lui le capitaine c'est vrai que un marin
il accepte la décision il respecte la
décision qui a été prise par le bas rhin
ou par le tacticien ça va dépendre si
c'est vraiment donc il ya vraiment
l'esprit d'équipé qui enfile bombay
c'est une erreur une erreur on la suit
tous pas de lien philosophique entre la
façon de gouverner un pays de tenir le
gouvernail d'un bateau sachant qu'il
faut un peu suivre le vent d'abord on va
regarder la météo avant de s'embarquer
sur un bateau regardez la météo c'est
voir là je dirai comment se comporte la
société comme alhaji comment elle et
qu'est ce que les gens attendent on a on
a des contraintes des consciences
humaines qui disent on va surfer quand
même sur les mots
les vents les vents contraires après il
faut il faut prendre une option et
l'assumé alors la politique c'est
d'abord une question de vocation et jean
paul mattei c'est un militant
la première heure qui a été engagé très
tôt oui il n'a pas honte de le dire
c'est un ex jeunes giscardiens je me
suis engagé en 74 bon high risk are thus
car à la ba ouai c j'avais le t-shirt
jusqu'à novembre le personnage me
fascine et parce qu'il juge que cette
espèce de hauteur et de distance giscard
à cette époque là il était rock'n'roll
le personnage était pas forcément rock
and roll mais il incarne et quand même
décidé rocha marcq était une nouvelle
à l'époque il y avait des concerts qu'il
y avait des grandes fêtes militante qui
a été fait à paris on me faisait monter
des buts d'écart le média vecchi
mireille mathieu carlos santana
alors là pas mal quand même
à l'époque c'est à dire surtout est-ce
que carlos santana ça mais pour qui
jouer à l'époque sédation aussi aussi
c'est vrai quand on regarde oui ça fait
ça fait marrer les gens oui jeunes
giscardiens on voit très bien avec le
pull machin tout ça moi je t'ai pas du
tout le temps alors bravo au gendarmes
aujourd'hui vous êtes d'accord giscard
c'est vintage sur le couple le t-shirt
giscard à la barre sa bru ça vaut une
fortune voyez là un bel exemple les
affiches aussi de campagne de l'époque
ça ça vaut très cher et d'ailleurs jean
paul bataille les collectionne mais au
fond alors est-ce que derrière cette
nostalgie il n'y aurait pas
potentiellement un espoir politique est
ce que aujourd'hui dans la perspective
de 2022
giscard ne serait pas un espoir
les idées qui étaient portés à l'époque
oui arrive est arrivé je dirais à
rassembler un peu toutes les tendances
qu'on est en train de vivre donc 2022
giscard à la barre ça pour être s autre
s nos normes et je suis pas sûr que ce
soit très porteur on savait pouvoir
ressentir le dis parce que je n'entrais
pas dans leur sens et le bar je vais me
faire charrier avec ça je vous ai alors
qu'amiens braves
j'adore ce que vous faites merci
revenez-vous nos vite jeudi prochain
avec d'autres fous rire allez on va
terminer comme chaque soir par le jour
d'après notre collection d'entretien sur
la praye corona des russes ce soir c'est
les céistes david djaïz qui analyse pour
nous le retour en force des états
nations dans cette crise sanitaire
regardez là on est sur ma terrasse
c'est comme un navire bonjour david diaz
aujourd'hui affirmant qu'avoir vous êtes
et ses listes enseignant à sciences po
et un peu avant la crise vous avez
publié un livre slow démocratie dans
lequel vous ne vous invitiez à mieux
maîtriser la mondialisation grâce aux
nations ces nations ces états nations
aujourd'hui semble être redevenue une
forme d'horizon indépassable
on le voit bien que ce soit en allemagne
en france en italie en espagne chacun y
va de sa stratégie
est-ce que c'est ces réjouissances
retour là en force des états nations où
c'est pas un peu désespérant je ne sais
pas si c'est réjouissant
désespérant mais ce qui est certain
c'est que face à une crise de cette
ampleur qui touche à la santé et donc à
la vie des gens puisque là on est sur
l'essentiel la sûreté la santé la
sécurité c'est l'essentiel pour les gens
en a une réaction un peu instinctive du
social vous avez vu les solidarités qui
s'expriment localement au niveau
familial amical professionnel et vous
avez de manière plus politiquement
organisée des solidarités qui s'exprime
au niveau national c'est comme ça que
j'interprète par exemple
fermetures de frontières un peu
désordonné qui se sont produites en
europe au début de la crise parce que
l'état nation
dans cette logique qu'on connaît depuis
offs finalement c'est celui qui nous
protège qui protège la vie et lorsque
l'épidémie est là d'une certaine manière
la vie est en danger et sept au rôle de
l'état régalien de protéger la en quoi
au fond ces nations peuvent être une
opportunité selon vous aujourd'hui dans
cette crise je pense que lorsque la
mondialisation qui en réalité est une
sino américano globalisation s'est
développé à partir de la fin des années
1970 on a considéré que la priorité
c'était la libération des flux de
capitaux de marchandises et au fond on a
un peu oublié que la démocratie et la
solidarité sociale s'était construite
dans les frontières des différents états
nations et que ça reposait sur un
certain nombre de compromis
par exemple le droit du travail par
exemple la solidarité sociale et que ces
compromis au fond il était très
important pour les gens et quand on a
ouvert les vannes en quelque sorte des
circulations de capitaux de marchandises
on a pu mettre en danger ses compromis
et c'est aujourd'hui ce qu'on redécouvre
avec une certaine acuité
par exemple notre incapacité à avoir une
autonomie stratégique sur des biens
aussi essentiel que les principes actifs
des médicaments les respirateurs les
dans la critique que vous faites de la
mondialisation
vous ne le faites pas comme étant la
cause de ce qui nous arrive mais plus
une forme d'accès d'amateurs c'est ça ça
n'est au fond ni la cause ni
l'accélérateur c'est plutôt le milieu
dans lequel se déploie cette crise c'est
vrai que le virus a été un peu l'agent
de l'intérieur des voies de la
mondialisation puisqu'il s'est propagée
en quelques jours de son épicentre qui
est one au reste du monde
en empruntant en quelque sorte les voies
aériennes avec les passagers mais ça
n'est pas pour autant que la
mondialisation doit être stigmatisés
comme une cause de ce qui nous arrive
en revanche c'est effectivement une
crise dans la mondialisation on voit
bien ce confinement planétaire la moitié
de l'humanité claquemuré chez elle
aujourd'hui
et donc il faut être capable
imaginez une autre gouvernance ou une
autre architecture de la mondialisation
qui permettent d'éviter la répétition et
la multiplication de ces crises et cet
autre gouvernance que j'appelle de mes
voeux bien sûr elle fait une plus grande
place à l'autonomie stratégie aux états
nations et à d'autres dimensions que la
seule dimension économique alors un état
stratège en état qui reprend une forme
de souveraineté stratégique sur certains
biens certains biens communs comme la
santé à quoi ressemblerait-il bat déjà
voilà métaphore que j'emploie ce ventre
c'est celle de lécluse c'est à dire que
il faut se représenter la mondialisation
comme un grand fleuve sur lequel tout
circule
sauf que entre les différents états
nations comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure il ya des droits du travail
différent il ya un rapport à la question
sociale qui est différent et puis il ya
aussi des systèmes productifs qui sont
plus ou moins polluants et l'enjeu d'une
écluse c'est quoi c'est de s'adapter en
quelque sorte aux différences social
culturel environnemental des nations
par exemple en mettant un ajustement
carbone aux frontières
donc l'idée c'est patent de
démondialiser ou de supprimer la
mondialisation ce qui paraît être un
voeu pieux la mondialisation n'est pas
un phénomène en off on n'est pas soi
dans la mondialisation soit dans la
démondialisation mais c'est plutôt de
construire une architecture dans
laquelle les compromis sociaux les
compromis démocratiques sont mieux pris
en compte et ça suppose effectivement
une action beaucoup plus résolue de la
puissance publique à commencer par
l'état vous parler par exemple de
reprendre le contrôle des biens publics
hors marché exemple est bien de manière
très concrète la santé ou
l'environnement ce sont des biens
publics qui sont hors marché et qui eux
ne connaissent pas les frontières
et vous voyez quand on a mis en place
cette mondialisation dans les années
1970 on a dit que tout circulent les
marchandises les capitaux mais on n'a
rien fait pour les biens publics
mondiaux regarder les chèques des coptes
successives
donc vous voyez bien que cette
mondialisation elle va bien tant qu'elle
encourage la libre circulation des
marchandises où le dumping
mais en revanche elle ne fait rien sur
les biens publics comme la santé ou
l'environnement
donc l'enjeu en fait c'est pas de
démondialiser mais c'est plutôt de
remettre la mondialisation sur ses pieds
de la refaire marcher à l'endroit en
priorisant les biens publics mondiaux en
priorisant les comportement coopératif
mais en revanche en redonnant aux
états-nations des marges de manoeuvre
stratégique lorsqu'il s'agit de se
protéger dans cette crise il ya eu
notamment dans l'aspect sanitaire
d'énormes problèmes de réactivité l'état
central démocratique avec une
administration lourde et des procédures
à respecter qui n'ont pas permis de la
fluidité de la réactivité
il faudra tirer les leçons de sa aussi
pour la presse bien sûr et d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant parce que cette crise
elle a été à la fois le révélateur de
l'impérieuse nécessité d'avoir un état
presque hobbesien au sens noble soyez
qui protège l'essentiel
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
la sûreté et la sécurité la santé et en
même temps on a pu constater
effectivement un certain nombre de
défaillances de l'anper et c'est pas
propre à la france ses propres certain
nombre de pays d'europe occidentale ou
aux états unis et donc l'enjeu qui va
falloir avoir c'est effectivement
l'enjeu de la la refondation des spas
pas simplement comme cette entité
surplombante voiliers qui est au dessus
de tous les acteurs qui est très
verticale etc mais plutôt comme cette
entité collaborative qui est capable de
passer on va dire des alliances ou des
who de travailler de manière coopérative
avec un certain nombre d'acteurs à
commencer par les collectivités locales
ils sont absolument nécessaires mais
aussi les entreprises les associations
et plus largement la société civile ou
parle beaucoup d'un repli ou d'un risque
de repli national on a vu surtout que
les états populistes ou les régimes ou
des systèmes politiques populistes voire
autoritaire ne s'en sont pas mieux sorti
que les démocraties libérales
bonne nouvelle il s'en sent même plus
mal sorti voyez par exemple la
communication erratique de donald trump
ou même la situation en hongrie où
viktor orban en quelque sorte profiter
de cette crise pour faire passer en
contrebande ce dont il rêvait depuis
toujours c'est-à-dire la suspension pure
et simple de l'état de droit
donc effectivement je pense que ça n'est
pas une aubaine pour les populistes
creed
parce que ils ont fait la démonstration
de leur amateurisme de paroles parfois
erratique de décisions peu coordonnés et
surtout d'une défiance vis-à-vis de la
science qui est problématique parce que
dans un moment de crise comme ça vous
avez besoin d'éclairer plus que jamais
vos décisions sur des analyses
scientifiques rigoureuses enfin david
djaïz il y à cette comparaison
incessante entre les états dans cette
crise qui va gagner et qui va perdre la
gestion de cette crise sanitaire
elle va laisser des traces cette
comparaison
cette comparaison les gens ne peuvent
pas s'empêcher de la faire parce que
d'abord tous les jours nous sommes
abreuvés d'informations en provenance du
monde
j'ai dit dans un article récent nous
n'avons jamais pris autant de nouvelles
du monde et c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs
que cette crise est ce que j'appelle une
crise monde c'est à dire une crise qui
fait qu on regarde tous les pays du
monde en même temps un peu comme pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale ont regardé
ce que faisait l'armée russe qui se
passait au brésil les alliances de
franco et c est là si vous voulez c'est
pareil vous regardez ce qui se passe
dans tous les pays du monde et il ya des
comparaisons qui sont faites qui sont à
mon avis totalement morbide et
inopportune parce que ce n'est pas une
compétition et ça devrait même être une
coopération mais j'y vois un enjeu
existentiel pour la démocratie libérale
c'est la capacité à démontrer sa
résilience et son efficacité
une résilience et une efficacité
supérieure au régime autoritaire parce
que vous voyez que les régimes
autoritaires ont déjà commencé
l'offensive pour montrer que leur
système de gouvernance et plus efficace
pour faire face à ces crises donc il ya
vraiment un enjeu existentiel pour la
démocratie de montrer que des décisions
éclairées par la science la liberté de
la presse
la transparence sur les données et sur
les informations qu'on communique et
aussi une relation de confiance entre le
gouvernement et le public sont
absolument non seulement meilleur que ce
qui existe dans les régimes autoritaires
mais nécessaire pour surmonter cette
crise sanitaire et éviter qu'elles ne
dégénèrent en une gigantesque crise
sociale politique et crise de
civilisation
merci david djaïz merci beaucoup
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi demain vous retrouverez
valérie brochard pour n'ayons pas peur
des mots très belle soirée documentaire
sur lcp
quant à moi je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]